Choiszt: 那个房间门要打开
Choiszt: That room's door needs to be opened.
Alice: 一楼扫完了吗
Alice: Is the first floor cleaned?
Jake:扫完了
Jake: It's done.
Jake: 那个你可以
Jake: So you can...
Jake: 反正反正
Jake: Anyway, anyway...
Jake: 我上去你们就可以到一楼
Jake: I'll go up, and you guys can stay on the first floor.
Alice:好累哦
Alice: So tired.
Alice: 我再也不想刷了
Alice: I don't want to scrub anymore.
Alice:全是这个味
Alice: It's all this smell.
Katrina:  你的灯灭了耶
Katrina: Your light is out.
Katrina: 你灯灭了
Alice: 我这有充电的呢
Alice: I have a charger here.
Alice:你要用吗
Alice: Do you need it?
Katrina:  哎又亮了
Katrina: Oh, it's on again.
Katrina:  哦不对那是他的反光
Katrina: Oh no, that's just a reflection.
Katrina:  对不起哈哈
Katrina: Sorry, haha.
Alice: 给
Alice: Here.
Katrina:  哎呀
Katrina: Oops.
Alice:有
Alice: Yes?
Alice: 给，你有线没
Alice: Do you have a wired one?
Lucia: 没有我线好像也在
Lucia: No, my cable seems to be here too.
Alice: 线是不是也是通用的吗
Alice: Aren't cables universal?
Lucia: 线可能是通用的我的线在盒子里
Lucia: The cable might be universal, mine's in the box.
Alice: 给
Alice: Here.
Alice: 你先冲我的吧
Alice: Charge mine first.
Lucia: 谢谢你要不要看一下你还有多少电
Lucia: Thanks. Do you want to check how much battery you have left?
Alice:我充了好久
Alice: I've been charging it for a long time.
Alice: 我还有77，你用
Alice: 哎
Alice: 千里共婵娟
Alice: Sharing the beauty of the moon from afar.
Alice: 你是没删吗
Alice: You haven't deleted it, right?
Lucia: 我们今天上午的这个不是
Lucia: This morning's one, no.
Lucia: 下午就是三点多的那个
Lucia: The one from the afternoon, around three, yes.
Lucia: 可以删掉了吗
Lucia: Can it be deleted?
Alice:对
Alice: Yes.
Lucia: 没事没事我不是没电了
Lucia: It's okay, it's okay, it's not out of battery.
Lucia: 他是没内存了
Lucia: It ran out of memory.
Lucia: 但是今天下午的那个应该已经导过了吧
Lucia: But the one from this afternoon should've been transferred already, right?
Choiszt:  反正先留着吧我不太清楚导没导
Choiszt: Just keep it for now. I'm not sure if it's transferred.
Lucia:  我把三点钟那个删了
Lucia: I'll delete the one from three o'clock.
Lucia: 应该导过一次然后我们晚上又拿到了那个
Lucia: It should've been transferred once, and then we got it again in the evening.
Tasha: 晚上录之前都把删掉了
Tasha: Delete everything before the evening recording.
Choiszt: 这个你先拿着你的已经删了是吗
Choiszt: Here, take this. You've already deleted yours, right?
Tasha: 嗯唉
Tasha: Yeah.
Katrina:  哎他是不是要
Katrina: Hey, does he need...
Katrina:  他是不是少了散粉啊噢噢
Katrina: Is he missing setting powder? Oh, oh!
Katrina:  哦对定妆喷雾
Katrina: Oh, right, setting spray.
Alice: 给我吧
Alice: 你还用吗
Alice: Do you still need it?
Lucia: 我把我这个先充上万一
Lucia: I'll charge mine just in case.
Katrina:  你会抽烟
Katrina: Do you smoke?
Katrina:  你会啊
Katrina: You do?
Shure:  老板请享用
Shure: Enjoy, boss.
Katrina:  哎呀哎呀哎呀
Katrina: Oh my gosh, oh my gosh!
Katrina:  你这下真成那种摇
Katrina: Now you really look like one of those rock...
Katrina:  滚的了就是
Katrina: Rollers!
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina:  很厉害很厉害
Katrina: So cool, so cool.
Shure:  这也没有爆珠吧
Shure: There's no flavor capsule, right?
Katrina:  哈哈眼影盘
Katrina: Hahaha, eyeshadow palette.
Nicous:  他说他自己买的妆前
Nicous: He said he bought the primer himself.
Nicous:  妆前和隔离
Nicous: Primer and base.
Nicous:  嗯对那是散粉
Nicous: Hmm, yeah, that's loose powder.
Katrina:  那是用在粉底液之前的
Katrina: That's used before foundation.
Katrina:  不是你这也太贴心了
Katrina: No way, you're just too considerate.
Katrina:  看见别人的幸福我就破防
Katrina: Seeing other people's happiness really gets to me.
Katrina:  你知道吗
Katrina: You know that?
Shure:  嘿嘿破防吧你就
Shure: Haha, it's getting to you, huh?
Katrina:  今天真让我大破防啊
Katrina: Today really broke me.
Katrina:  本来开开心心
Katrina: I was so happy before.
Nicous: 我来给你介绍好了
Nicous: Let me introduce you then.
Katrina:  长得帅的
Katrina: A handsome one.
Katrina:  我在我们武汉理工呆四年
Katrina: I spent four years at Wuhan University of Technology.
Katrina:  没见到一个帅哥
Katrina: Didn't see a single handsome guy.
Katrina:  倒也不是眼光高
Katrina: It's not like my standards are high.
Nicous: 你需要多高的
Nicous: How high do you need?
Katrina:  一米八
Katrina: Six feet.
Lucia: 哦那个五点的也可以删了好的
Lucia: Oh, you can delete the 5 PM one too.
Katrina:  我靠
Katrina: Oh my god.
Katrina:  给你拍张艺术照
Katrina: Let me take an artistic photo of you.
Katrina:  你就这样你这样
Katrina: Just like this, like this.
Shure:  可以可以可以
Shure: Sure, sure, sure.
Katrina:  私下烟酒都来呀
Katrina: We can smoke and drink in private.
Katrina:  哈哈哈特别像我一个表弟
Katrina: Haha, you look a lot like one of my cousins.
Shure:  哎你们都不喝
Shure: Hey, you guys aren't drinking?
Katrina:  再喝晚上还写毕设呢
Katrina: If I drink more, how will I finish my thesis tonight?
Shure:  几点了哥
Shure: What time is it, bro?
Shure:  10点了还写毕设呢
Shure: It's 10 PM and you're still working on your thesis?
Katrina:  那没别的时间呀
Katrina: There's no other time.
Katrina:  早上起不来
Katrina: I can't get up in the morning.
Katrina:  只有晚上工作
Katrina: I can only work at night.
Shure:  明天早上我叫你
Shure: I'll wake you up tomorrow morning.
Shure:  咱俩一起写毕设
Shure: We'll write our theses together.
Katrina:  好吧
Katrina: Okay.
Katrina:  几点钟
Katrina: What time?
Shure:  8点钟起写毕设
Shure: 8 AM, we'll start writing.
Shure:  你写不写
Shure: Are you writing or not?
Katrina:  我靠
Katrina: Oh my god.
Shure: 我现在
Shure: I'll write now.
Shure:  咱再来一杯
Shure: Let's have another drink.
Shure:  然后咱8点起来写毕设
Shure: Then we'll get up at 8 to write.
Shure:  好吧
Shure: Alright.
Katrina:  不
Katrina: No.
Katrina:  坚定原则
Katrina: Stick to principles
Shure:  咦好坚定
Shure: Wow, so firm
Katrina:  等我今天把事弄完了
Katrina: Let me finish things today
Katrina:  明天跟你喝
Katrina: I'll drink with you tomorrow
Katrina:  今天是第几天
Katrina: What day is it today?
Katrina:  第第二天第三天
Katrina: Second or third day?
Katrina:  还早着呢
Katrina: It's still early
Katrina:  明天还要拍那个yesok
Katrina: We still have to shoot that yesok tomorrow
Katrina:  yesok
Katrina: yesok
Katrina:  你今天晚上去学
Katrina: You go learn it tonight
Katrina:  你来教行吗
Katrina: Can you teach me?
Katrina:  不想教
Katrina: Don't want to teach
Shure:  我可以给你查拍子
Shure: I can help you check the beats
Shure:  我查拍子绝对牛逼
Shure: I'm really good at checking beats
Shure:  我跟你讲
Shure: I'm telling you
Shure:  怎么遭哇
Shure: What's wrong?
Katrina:  怎么着吧打一架
Katrina: Wanna fight?
Katrina:  其实我觉得这个地方完全可以翻进来
Katrina: Actually, I think this place can be accessed completely
Katrina:  这里又没有门又没有密码
Katrina: There's no door or password here
Katrina:  哦也是你们帮忙挑的
Katrina: Oh, it's the one you guys chose
Katrina:  他的优势是
Katrina: His advantage is
Katrina:  哦哦对
Katrina: Oh, right
Katrina:  嗯我当时
Katrina: Yeah, at that time
Katrina:  我当时一直以为是三个人住一个房间
Katrina: I thought it was three people in one room
Katrina:  你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Shure:  为什么不是三个人住一个房间
Shure: Why isn't it three people in one room?
Nicous:  那你就跟杨老板住一个房间
Nicous: Then you stay with Jake in one room
Nicous:  不是三个人是两两
Nicous: It's not three people, it's pairs
Katrina:  他5点睡
Katrina: He sleeps at 5
Katrina:  你几点睡
Katrina: What time do you sleep?
Shure:  我以为是跟女嘉宾住一个房间
Shure: I thought I was sharing a room with a female guest
Katrina:  这话赶紧给他录下来
Katrina: Record this quickly
Katrina:  给他女朋友发过去
Katrina: Send it to his girlfriend
Shure:  你滚犊子吧你
Shure: Get lost, will you
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Hmm
Shure:  哎你知道吗
Shure: Hey, you know what
Shure:  我我们俩
Shure: We both
Shure:  我俩五一一一起回长春你知道吗
Shure: We both are going back to Changchun for May Day, you know?
Katrina:  那这不得见一波家长啊
Katrina: Then you must be meeting the parents
Shure:  你知道这个小红帽子梗吗
Shure: Do you know the joke about Little Red Riding Hood?
Katrina:  啊我室友也是
Katrina: Ah, my roommate too.
Katrina:  就是男生的妈妈来找他
Katrina: It's like the guy's mom comes to find him.
Katrina:  对就是
Katrina: Yeah, exactly.
Katrina:  但是但是
Katrina: But, but...
Katrina:  这样子的话也有有好也有不好
Katrina: This kind of thing has its pros and cons.
Katrina:  那要是你以后换女朋友
Katrina: What if you change girlfriends later?
Katrina:  你妈不得哄下一个
Katrina: Your mom has to flatter the next one.
Shure:  我本我本来买的那个杭州
Shure: I originally bought that Hangzhou...
Shure:  直接去长春的那个高铁票
Shure: ...high-speed train ticket directly to Changchun.
Katrina:  你女朋友啊
Katrina: Your girlfriend, huh?
Katrina:  哎呀你们俩够抽象的
Katrina: Oh my, you two are so abstract.
Katrina:  不是你你们俩
Katrina: No, you two...
Katrina:  呃你们俩就那个软件上认识以后
Katrina: Uh, you guys met on that app and then...
Katrina:  那见面了吗
Katrina: ...did you meet up in person?
Katrina:  然后见面就表白在一起了
Katrina: And then you confessed and got together?
Katrina:  他给你写的
Katrina: Did she write it to you?
Katrina:  唉哈哈
Katrina: Haha...
Katrina:  感觉每个人的事情都很神奇
Katrina: Feels like everyone's stories are so magical.
Katrina:  那就是见面了的时候
Katrina: So when you met up...
Katrina:  就互相彼此心动了呗
Katrina: ...you both had feelings for each other?
Katrina:  看对眼了呗
Katrina: You clicked, right?
Katrina:  哦确实一开始就眼熟嘛
Katrina: Oh, you recognized each other from the start.
Katrina:  你不是说很抽象吗你这个
Katrina: Didn't you say it was abstract, though?
Katrina:  特别喜欢听别人讲八卦
Katrina: I really love hearing gossip.
Katrina:  因为我在学校圈子其实就我舍
Katrina: Because in my school circle, it's just my roommates.
Katrina:  友然后我舍友几个要么就有男朋友
Katrina: And my roommates either have boyfriends...
Katrina:  一直高中谈到现在
Katrina: ...dating since high school...
Katrina:  要么就是不跟男的说一句话
Katrina: ...or they don't talk to guys at all.
Katrina:  就没有没有八卦就是我说我
Katrina: So there's no gossip, it's just me.
Katrina:  我在学校里圈子比较小
Katrina: My school circle is pretty small.
Katrina:  就没听见什么八卦
Katrina: So I don't hear any gossip.
Katrina:  我们哎太喜欢认识新的人了
Katrina: We love meeting new people.
Shure:  我们想想听你的八卦
Shure: We want to hear your gossip.
Katrina:  我就一段
Katrina: I only have one.
Nicous: 说宝宝早安
Nicous: Saying good morning, baby.
Nicous:  然后第二天就跟我前女友奔现了
Nicous: And the next day, I met up with my ex-girlfriend.
Katrina:  谁谁谁谁
Katrina: Who, who, who?
Nicous:  我刚说的第二天说宝宝早安
Nicous: The next day after I said good morning, baby.
Nicous:  第二天就跟我前女友有奔现了
Nicous: The next day, I met up with my ex-girlfriend in real life.
Katrina:  你
Katrina: You...
Katrina:  你跟你前女友关宣
Katrina: You and your ex-girlfriend were...
Katrina:  暧昧
Katrina: ...flirting?
Nicous:  一开始暧昧
Nicous: At first, yes.
Nicous:  后来已经g了
Nicous: Then it got serious.
Nicous:  后来他私信不理我
Nicous: Later, she ignored my private messages.
Nicous:  他说他在忙
Nicous: She said she was busy.
Nicous:  然后我以为我跟他就是朋友处了
Nicous: So I thought we were just friends.
Nicous:  然后我就直接跟
Nicous: Then I just...
Nicous:  然后后来就跟我前女友认识了
Nicous: Then I got to know my ex-girlfriend.
Nicous:  就是不认识了
Nicous: Well, didn't know her at first.
Katrina:  也就是说
Katrina: So you mean...
Katrina:  你跟你现女友认识的比你前女友早
Katrina: You knew your current girlfriend before your ex-girlfriend?
Nicous:  然后然后我就直接发过来
Nicous: Then I just sent it to her directly.
Nicous:  我也没隐瞒他我就他看见了
Nicous: I didn't hide anything from her, she saw it.
Nicous:  然后他就说好吧然后
Nicous: Then she was like, "Okay, fine."
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha!
Nicous:  过了一段时间过了一段时间
Nicous: After some time...
Nicous:  他买了个机票直接来北京
Nicous: She bought a plane ticket and flew to Beijing.
Nicous:  他然后他到了晚上跟我讲他到了
Nicous: She told me when she arrived at night.
Nicous:  让我晚上出来接他
Nicous: She asked me to pick her up.
Katrina:  但是那时你分手了吗
Katrina: But had you broken up by then?
Nicous:  没分的我刚来北京
Nicous: No, we hadn't. I had just arrived in Beijing.
Nicous:  然后关键最惆怅的是我他妈睡着了
Nicous: The most frustrating part was, I fell asleep.
Nicous:  没看见嗯你邀请他飞走了吧哦
Nicous: I didn't see her message. She probably left after that, right?
Katrina:  但是我觉得这女生还蛮有勇气的
Katrina: But I think this girl was quite brave.
Nicous:  然后后来就都互删了
Nicous: Then we deleted each other.
Katrina:  互删了后来又加上了
Katrina: Deleted, but then re-added?
Nicous:  后来我女朋友老出轨
Nicous: Then my girlfriend kept cheating.
Nicous:  我就不想跟我女朋友谈了
Nicous: I didn't want to be with her anymore.
Nicous:  但是我就把他加回来了
Nicous: So I added her back.
Nicous:  然后但是那时候没想跟他谈恋爱
Nicous: But I didn't plan to date her.
Nicous:  我一直都是加回来了
Nicous: I just added her back, that's all.
Nicous:  然后抱歉一下干嘛
Nicous: Then, sorry, what was I saying?
Katrina:  但是你那也有点像就
Katrina: But you know, it kind of feels like...
Katrina:  在他的视角有点像断崖式暧昧耶
Katrina: ...from her perspective, like a sudden break in the relationship.
Katrina:  就是本来暧昧很好的然后突然跟别人
Katrina: Like things were going well, then you suddenly started seeing someone else.
Katrina:  四天四天就能代表什么
Katrina: Four days, can that really mean anything?
Shure:  四天我这四年里
Shure: Four days? In four years...
Katrina:  我这五年的
Katrina: I've had this for five years.
Shure:  不喝点了吗
Shure: Not gonna have a drink?
Shure:  雨轩
Shure: Yuxuan.
Katrina:  你给我整点呗
Katrina: Can you get me some?
Shure:  给你整点
Shure: I'll get you some.
Katrina:  你当心他进去了
Katrina: Be careful, he might get in trouble.
Katrina:  他家很有钱吗
Katrina: Is his family rich?
Katrina:  我去那确实有点啊
Katrina: When I went there, it really seemed like it.
Katrina:  那确实
Katrina: That's true.
Katrina:  飞来飞去
Katrina: Flying all over the place.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Katrina:  就是在一直就跟他在一起
Katrina: Just always being with him.
Katrina:  就是我靠你都同居还能出轨哈哈哈
Katrina: I mean, wow, you were living together and still cheated. Haha.
Katrina:  我靠你给我少搞一点点
Katrina: Wow, give me a break.
Katrina:  你前女友是表演型人格吗
Katrina: Was your ex-girlfriend a drama queen?
Katrina:  啊你俩谁也不缺啊
Katrina: Ah, neither of you were lacking anything.
Katrina:  他分了你也分了
Katrina: He broke up, you broke up.
Katrina:  然后你俩在一起了
Katrina: Then you two got together.
Katrina:  怎么不算一种缘分呢
Katrina: How is that not considered fate?
Katrina:  我靠你给我搞这么多东西
Katrina: Oh my god, you gave me so much stuff.
Katrina:  晚上要一直上厕所
Katrina: I'll be running to the bathroom all night.
Katrina:  看柚子好不好喝哈
Katrina: Let's see if this pomelo drink is any good.
Katrina:  哎还行
Katrina: Hmm, it's alright.
Katrina:  感觉比橙汁好喝
Katrina: Feels better than orange juice.
Shure:  他那个西柚和橙汁
Shure: His grapefruit and orange juice.
Shure:  都是比较比较不错的
Shure: They're both pretty good.
Shure:  谁要来打扰我的乌托邦
Shure: Who dares to disturb my utopia?
Alice: 进水了好像
Alice: Looks like some water got in.
Shure: 知道这这首叫什么吗
Shure: Do you know what this song is called?
Shure:  谁要来打扰我的乌托邦
Shure: Who dares to disturb my utopia?
Shure:  我马上掏出我的枪
Shure: I'll pull out my gun right away.
Shure:  初中的时候
Shure: Back in middle school.
Alice: 这有个找个小瑕疵
Alice: There's a tiny flaw here.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahaha
Shure:  哈哈
Shure: Haha
Shure:  乌托邦我想了一首歌
Shure: Utopia, I thought of a song.
Katrina:  我初中的时候还在暗恋别人
Katrina: In middle school, I was still secretly in love with someone.
Katrina:  暗恋别人
Katrina: Secretly in love with someone.
Katrina:  说就是就是
Katrina: If I say it is, then it is.
Katrina:  喜欢找人说话
Katrina: I like talking to people.
Katrina:  因为因为他从来身边没有女生
Katrina: Because, because he never had any girls around him.
Katrina:  然后我在想
Katrina: Then I thought,
Katrina:  我喜欢三年不会是
Katrina: I've liked him for three years, could it be...
Shure:  都他妈是姐妹
Shure: They're all like sisters.
Katrina:  而且又不会有这种
Katrina: And also, there's no such...
Katrina:  刚去成都的时候找我舍友
Katrina: When I first went to Chengdu, I looked for my roommate.
Katrina:  我舍友就带着他们陈启的那个闺蜜哇
Katrina: My roommate brought along their friend Chen Qi.
Katrina:  就是
Katrina: It was just...
Katrina:  刚好在他们陈启那后面的小吃街里
Katrina: Right in the snack street behind Chen Qi's place.
Katrina:  吃饭他说他说你看嘛
Katrina: While we were eating, he said, "Look at that."
Katrina:  这也是我们体院比较有名的那
Katrina: "That's one of our famous ones."
Katrina:  哈哈哈我舔你知道吗
Katrina: Haha, do you know how I sucked up to him?
Katrina:  舔了以后就还要还要call back
Katrina: After sucking up, I had to call back.
Katrina: 我那个舍友
Katrina: My roommate...
Katrina:  就你在图书馆crush
Katrina: You had a crush on someone in the library.
Katrina:  在我们这算算下流货势
Katrina: In our place, that's considered a low move.
Katrina:  哈哈陈启真好多帅哥
Katrina: Haha, Chen Qi has so many handsome guys.
Katrina:  嗯感觉太潮了你知道吗
Katrina: It feels so trendy, you know?
Katrina:  真是太潮了
Katrina: It's really so trendy.
Katrina:  然后一个个一米八
Katrina: And each of them is 1.8 meters tall.
Katrina:  然后那种走路
Katrina: And the way they walk...
Katrina:  就是那种
Katrina: It's like...
Shure:  来一杯吗
Shure: Want a drink?
Katrina:  然后那个双开门
Katrina: Then those double doors...
Shure:  走
Shure: Let's go.
Shure:  这悲伤玩具
Shure: This sad toy.
Shure:  对
Shure: Yeah.
Shure:  一个也很不错的乐队
Shure: It's actually a pretty good band.
Choiszt:  我不知道他会不会再来
Choiszt: I don't know if he'll come back.
Choiszt:  一楼再扫一遍哎
Choiszt: Let's sweep the first floor again.
Shure:  不
Shure: No.
Shure:  我是因为整个圈子都要抽
Shure: It's because everyone in the circle smokes.
Shure:  我我我没有
Shure: I, I, I...
Shure:  没有办法
Shure: I had no choice.
Shure:  不
Shure: No.
Shure: 喝酒是让你快乐
Shure: Drinking makes you happy.
Nicous:  但是抽烟能让人
Nicous: But smoking can make you
Nicous:  冷静就我
Nicous: Calm down, like I...
Shure:  你滚吧就我
Shure: Get lost, like I...
Shure:  别听他的
Shure: Don't listen to him.
Shure:  喝酒就好
Shure: Just drink.
Katrina:  但是喝酒确实
Katrina: But drinking actually...
Katrina:  比如说晚上有事
Katrina: For instance, when you have something at night,
Katrina:  让人压力又很大喝酒
Katrina: It can make you more stressed when you drink.
Shure:  非常好的状态
Shure: It's a great state.
Katrina:  当时你知道
Katrina: At that time, you know,
Katrina:  我刚分手那会
Katrina: When I just broke up,
Katrina:  我室友他们没有offer
Katrina: My roommates didn't have job offers.
Katrina:  然后就因为我们室友基本都保研
Katrina: Because most of my roommates were guaranteed postgrad studies.
Katrina:  然后然后就没人说话
Katrina: And then no one talked to each other.
Katrina:  没人说话我就他们天天在图书馆
Katrina: No one talked, and they were in the library every day.
Katrina:  我就一个人在宿舍
Katrina: I was alone in the dormitory.
Katrina:  卧槽我前男友
Katrina: Damn, my ex-boyfriend,
Katrina:  够抽象我跟你讲
Katrina: It's abstract, let me tell you.
Katrina:  我前男友当时嗯
Katrina: My ex-boyfriend at that time, hmm...
Katrina:  他你知道
Katrina: You know,
Alice: 这好像不是纯
Alice: This doesn't seem purely...
Alice: 有一点点
Alice: A little bit...
Katrina:  有的时候会一起看综艺
Katrina: Sometimes we would watch variety shows together.
Katrina:  就是开腾讯会议嘛
Katrina: Like on Tencent Meetings.
Alice: 有一道
Alice: There's a...
Katrina:  他觉得我不陪他看那个短视频
Katrina: He thought I didn't watch short videos with him.
Katrina:  因为我觉得我刚看过
Katrina: Because I felt like I had just watched them.
Katrina:  我给他推荐
Katrina: I recommended them to him.
Katrina:  他就跟我就是那种撒娇的人
Katrina: And he was the kind who would act cute.
Katrina:  就是不嘛
Katrina: Like, no way.
Katrina:  我一定要有女朋友看
Katrina: I must have a girlfriend watch with me.
Katrina:  但是我不吃这一套
Katrina: But I don't play along with that.
Katrina:  你知道我也从来不跟我男朋友撒娇
Katrina: You know, I never act cute with my boyfriend.
Katrina:  我从来不撒娇
Katrina: I never act cute.
Katrina:  我再次总结
Katrina: In conclusion,
Katrina:  就是再怎么喜欢我都不撒娇
Katrina: No matter how much I like someone, I never act cute.
Katrina:  我撒不出来
Katrina: I can't do it.
Katrina:  我觉得很恶心
Katrina: I find it disgusting.
Katrina:  然后
Katrina: And then...
Katrina:  然后然后就这件事其实也没多大人
Katrina: And then, this whole thing wasn't a big deal.
Katrina:  就晚上稍微说一下就过了
Katrina: We could've talked it out that night.
Katrina:  然后他就一直就那死态度
Katrina: But he just kept that attitude.
Katrina:  然后就一直不说话
Katrina: And he wouldn't talk.
Katrina:  然后到第二天
Katrina: Then the next day...
Katrina:  等到第二天下午2点多回去
Katrina: He didn't come back until 2 PM.
Katrina:  而且我们已经是在一起5年了
Katrina: And we've been together for 5 years.
Katrina:  就是这个相处模式
Katrina: This is how we interact.
Katrina:  还是这个样子
Katrina: Always like this.
Katrina:  就是冷战
Katrina: Just a cold war.
Katrina:  他没多大点事他都不愿
Katrina: Even over small things, he won't apologize.
Katrina:  意低头那种
Katrina: He just won't give in.
Katrina:  然后我我晚上两点没睡着
Katrina: And I couldn't sleep until 2 AM.
Katrina:  我正准备给他发小作文呢
Katrina: I was ready to write him a long message.
Katrina:  你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Katrina:  就是复盘复盘
Katrina: Just to go over everything again.
Katrina:  然后呢然后发现突然一下就说
Katrina: And then, suddenly...
Katrina:  凭什么又是我发
Katrina:  哈哈凭什么又是我先发
Katrina: Haha, why do I always have to go first?
小黄: 他从来不低头是吧
Nicous: He never bows his head, right?
Katrina:  基本不低头
Katrina: Basically never.
Nicous:  最后前女友给我讲过一个
Nicous: My ex-girlfriend once told me...
Nicous:  讲过一句话嗯
Nicous: She said something, hmm...
Nicous:  不然这辈子不会向我低头
Nicous: That she would never bow to me in her life.
Nicous:  我说你滚
Nicous: I told her to get lost.
Katrina:  就是大家有有事好像
Katrina: It’s like everyone, when there’s an issue...
Katrina:  其实我是那种吃软不吃硬的
Katrina: Actually, I’m the kind who can be softened but not hardened.
Katrina:  你只要给我稍微给我一个台阶下
Katrina: You just need to give me a way out...
Katrina:  我就马上我们俩好好沟通了
Katrina: And I’ll communicate with you nicely.
Katrina:  就过了我不记仇那种
Katrina: I don’t hold grudges.
Katrina:  然后但是
Katrina: But then...
Katrina:  然后我第二天知道他有早八
Katrina: I knew he had an 8 AM class the next day.
Katrina:  但是他一直没有给我发消息
Katrina: But he didn’t message me at all.
Katrina:  就是到下午两两3点
Katrina: Until like 2 or 3 PM.
Katrina:  然后我就给他就把我小作文打打回去
Katrina: So I sent him a long message.
Katrina:  然后就当时也比较失望
Katrina: I was pretty disappointed at that time.
Katrina:  然后我就提了分手嘛
Katrina: And then I broke up with him.
Katrina:  然后然后呢
Katrina: So then...
Katrina:  他就说啊
Katrina: He just said...
Katrina:  他回的特别幼稚你知道吗
Katrina: He replied in such a childish way, you know?
Tasha: 他说什么
Tasha: What did he say?
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈永远在等这一句
Katrina: Hahaha, always waiting for this line.
Katrina:  我当时这句我觉得下头
Katrina: When he said that, I thought it was a turn-off.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Katrina:  这不我给你分析的问题了吗
Katrina: Didn't I already analyze the problem for you?
Katrina:  你就哈哈哈
Katrina: And you just laughed.
Katrina:  他这句话
Katrina: He said that
Katrina:  一下又把这个道德包袱一下甩我身上
Katrina: and threw this moral burden on me.
Katrina:  说我我总提分手
Katrina: Saying I always mention breaking up.
Katrina:  我我靠
Katrina: I mean, come on,
Katrina:  我几年没提分手了
Katrina: I haven't mentioned breaking up for years.
Alice: 这个好像有一点
Alice: That seems a bit true.
Katrina:  大一的时候喜欢你
Katrina: I liked you in freshman year.
Tasha: 瑕疵吗？
Katrina:  然后后来
Katrina: And then later,
Alice: 恩
Katrina:  那我话还没说完呢
Katrina: I hadn't even finished speaking.
Katrina:  我说你看我干嘛
Katrina: I asked, why are you looking at me?
Alice: 裂纹
Katrina:  然后我就把这发过去
Katrina: Then I sent this over,
Katrina:  然后就红感叹号了
Katrina: and it showed a red exclamation mark.
Katrina:  然后红感叹号以后
Katrina: After the red exclamation mark,
Katrina:  然后再说看其他平台吧
Katrina: I checked other platforms.
Katrina:  都是红感叹号
Katrina: All of them had red exclamation marks.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Katrina:  抖音QQ
Katrina: TikTok, QQ,
Katrina:  然后包括我的b站
Katrina: even my Bilibili account.
Katrina:  然后所有都被拉黑了
Katrina: All of them were blocked.
Nicous:  蓄谋已久
Nicous: It was premeditated.
Katrina:  非常的侮辱人
Katrina: It was very insulting.
Katrina:  然后
Katrina: Then,
Katrina:  然后我就就觉得无所谓了
Katrina: I just felt it didn't matter anymore.
Katrina:  算了算了
Katrina: Forget it, forget it.
Katrina:  就这样吧
Katrina: Just let it be.
Katrina:  然后等他十天后直接给我打个电话说
Katrina: Then ten days later, he called me and said
Katrina:  他到武汉了
Katrina: he was in Wuhan.
Katrina:  我说就是我
Katrina: I said, I mean,
Katrina:  那那十天就一直吃不好睡不好啥的
Katrina: those ten days, I couldn't eat or sleep well.
Katrina:  就是你明明理性上会觉得
Katrina: Rationally, I knew
Katrina:  你们俩在一起确实比较痛苦
Katrina: we were miserable together.
Katrina:  就没必要在一起了
Katrina: There was no need to stay together.
Katrina:  但是你晚上的时候
Katrina: But at night,
Katrina:  还是会想到以前开心的事情
Katrina: I'd still think about the happy times.
Katrina:  因为觉得哎
Katrina: I felt like, hey
Katrina:  怎么就5年就走到现在这个地步了
Katrina: How did we get to this point in just 5 years?
Katrina:  好歹也是学生时代
Katrina: After all, it was our student days
Katrina:  就这样就跟自己走上来
Katrina: And we just went through it together
Katrina:  然后呢就在前一天刚要复盘完
Katrina: Then the day before, when we were about to wrap up
Katrina:  就觉得就克服过去了
Katrina: I felt like we had overcome it
Katrina:  然后他第二天给我打电话说到武汉站
Katrina: Then the next day he called me saying he arrived at Wuhan station
Katrina:  然后到武汉站了以后
Katrina: After he got to Wuhan station
Katrina:  我就说那天哪见面呢
Katrina: I asked where we should meet up
Katrina:  感觉特奇怪你知道吗
Katrina: It felt really weird, you know?
Katrina:  饭也不想跟他吃
Katrina: I didn't even want to have a meal with him
Katrina:  我就说那你来我们学校吧
Katrina: So I told him to come to our school
Katrina:  来学校操场走一圈
Katrina: We could walk around the school track
Katrina:  走一圈他们当时那样子特别惨
Katrina: As we walked, they looked really miserable
Katrina:  就是就是
Katrina: Like, like
Katrina:  哈哈哈整个人非常颓废你知道吗
Katrina: Haha, they looked so depressed, you know?
Katrina:  我说哎呦这个死样子我真服了
Katrina: I was like, oh my god, I can't believe this look
Katrina:  就是嗯
Katrina: I mean, um
Katrina:  就是
Katrina: Like
Katrina:  整个人就搞得像那种抑郁症一样
Katrina: They looked like they had depression or something
Katrina:  就是就这样锤的
Katrina: Just beaten down like that
Katrina:  然后他跟我说
Katrina: Then he told me
Katrina:  他这10天不找我是因为他的胃
Katrina: That he hadn't contacted me for 10 days because of his stomach
Katrina:  肠胃不舒服
Katrina: His stomach was upset
Katrina:  然后不是有情绪器官吗
Katrina: You know, it's like an emotional organ
Katrina:  就情绪不好
Katrina: He wasn't feeling well
Katrina:  然后导致肠胃不舒服
Katrina: And it caused his stomach issues
Katrina:  就去校医院一直呃检查来着
Katrina: So he kept going to the school clinic for checkups
Katrina:  我说你不会加个微信吗
Katrina: I was like, couldn't you just add me on WeChat?
Katrina:  你说但凡想想挽回一点
Katrina: You know, if you really wanted to make things better
Katrina:  你都可以加个微信说一下
Katrina: You could've added me on WeChat and said something
Katrina:  哎就我们稍微冷静一下
Katrina: Like, let's just take a little break
Katrina:  但是我并不是想真的很分手对吧
Katrina: But I don't really want to break up, right?
Lucia: 我手机快没电了
Lucia: My phone's running out of battery
Alice: 这有充电宝
Alice: There's a power bank here
Lucia: 但没有线
Lucia: But there's no cable
Alice: 上面还有自带的
Alice: It has a built-in cable
Alice: 你看这个
Alice: Look at this
Lucia: 哎可以可以
Lucia: Oh, that's great
Lucia: 我可以充一下吗谢谢
Lucia: Can I use it to charge? Thanks
Shure:  想想我们了吗杨老板
Shure: Did you miss us, Jake?
Shure:  来来坐坐一会坐一会
Shure: Come, come, have a seat for a while.
Shure:  给杨老板拿拿凳子来
Shure: Get a chair for Jake.
Alice: 啊
Alice: Ah
Alice: 然后我看他里面有没有什么小气泡啊
Alice: And then I check if there are any small bubbles inside.
Alice: 小裂缝啥的
Alice: Or any little cracks.
Alice: 因为我最近摔他有几次
Alice: Because I've dropped it a few times recently.
Alice: 我怕里面有小裂纹
Alice: I'm worried there might be small cracks inside.
Lucia: 这是蛋白石哦
Lucia: This is an opal.
Alice: 恩
Alice: 我发现里面进水了
Alice: I noticed water got inside.
Shure:  明晚烤串
Shure: BBQ tomorrow night.
Alice: 就是这个托跟这个石头
Alice: It's between the base and the stone.
Alice: 里面有一点点水渍
Alice: There's a little bit of water stain inside.
Lucia: 是这个只有这边
Lucia: Is this only on this side?
Lucia: 是你自己设计的
Lucia: Did you design this yourself?
Alice: 整个
Alice: The whole thing.
Lucia: 啊好好看
Lucia: Oh, it looks so good.
Alice: 我比较喜欢海星
Alice: I really like starfish.
Alice: 上面镶了钻石
Alice: There's a diamond set on top.
Alice: 虽然有点小
Alice: Even though it's a bit small.
Alice: 不够闪耀
Alice: It's not shiny enough.
Lucia: 好看的
Lucia: It looks nice.
Alice: 这火彩还挺好的
Alice: The play of color is pretty good too.
Shure:  来走一个
Shure: Come on, let's go.
Shure:  没电了
Shure: The battery is dead.
Alice:比较活
Alice: It's quite lively.
Alice:很喜欢
Alice: I really like it.
Lucia: 真的好好看
Lucia: It's really beautiful.
Lucia: 我也特别喜欢闪闪发亮的东西
Lucia: I also love shiny things.
Alice: 在说话吗
Alice: Are you talking?
Lucia: 我是不是现在该
Lucia: Should I now...
Lucia: 赶快把我的照片墙买回来
Lucia: Hurry up and buy my photo wall back?
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Alice:什么
Alice: What?
Jake:一会我们讲讲自己
Jake: In a while, let's talk about ourselves.
Jake: 房间怎么安排
Jake: How to arrange the rooms.
Jake: 今天就结束了
Jake: Today will end here.
Jake: 然后明天早上交换礼物
Jake: And then we'll exchange gifts tomorrow morning.
Jake: 呃然后下午就去他们说的公园是吧
Jake: Uh, and then we'll go to the park they mentioned in the afternoon, right?
Jake: 你们讨论过吗
Jake: Have you guys discussed it?
Lucia: 我们没讨论出去什么公园
Lucia: We didn't discuss which park to go to.
Lucia: 因为不知道附近有什么公园
Lucia: Because we don't know what parks are nearby.
Alice: 那一波讨论了
Alice: That discussion happened.
Jake: 那你们没有讨论
Jake: So you guys didn't discuss it.
Alice: 都可以
Alice: It's all good.
Lucia: 对我们follow他们的idea
Lucia: Yeah, we followed their idea.
Jake:挺好
Jake: Pretty good.
Jake: 那明天就这样
Jake: So that's settled for tomorrow.
Jake: 主要是等快递吧
Jake: Mainly waiting for the delivery.
Jake: 就是快递周五到大概会吗
Jake: The delivery should arrive by Friday, right?
Jake: 你们如果有快递的话
Jake: If you have any deliveries.
Alice: 我们那个布置是需要落地的吗
Alice: Do we need to set it up on the ground?
Lucia: 需要落地吗
Lucia: Does it need to be on the ground?
Alice: 落地的话不一定能到吧
Alice: If it does, it might not arrive in time.
Lucia: 对那感觉
Lucia: Yeah, it feels like
Alice: 现在是周三
Alice: Today is Wednesday.
Lucia: 四五六
Lucia: Thursday, Friday, Saturday.
Alice: 对
Alice: Right.
Alice: 有点呛
Alice: It's a bit tight.
Alice: 哎呦卧槽
Alice: Oh, damn.
Lucia: 然后一些小装饰
Lucia: Then some small decorations.
Alice:我是
Alice: I am
Lucia: 因为我那个房子里面那个架子
Lucia: Because that shelf in my house
Lucia: 不太好布置
Lucia: is not easy to decorate.
Lucia: 我想买一个小一点的小桌
Lucia: I want to buy a smaller table
Lucia: 然后给他盖一个桌布
Lucia: and put a tablecloth on it.
Alice: 地毯桌布
Alice: A rug and a tablecloth.
Lucia: 理论上说一般三天应该是可以到的
Lucia: Theoretically, it should arrive in three days.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Lucia: 就是如果我们今天晚上确定要落地的
Lucia: If we decide to ground it tonight,
Lucia: 话就
Lucia: then
Jake:今晚下单
Jake: Place the order tonight.
Jake: 去京东明日达
Jake: Use JD's next-day delivery.
Lucia: 哦对
Lucia: Oh, right.
Lucia: 如果有京东明日达能能到的东西
Lucia: If there's something available with JD's next-day delivery,
Lucia: 在京东明日达上买优秀
Lucia: we should buy it on JD's next-day delivery.
Jake: 明日吧或者星期五到应该都没问题
Jake: It should be fine if it arrives by tomorrow or Friday.
Lucia: 我看一眼今天的
Lucia: Let me check today's
Alice: 可以进去了吗
Alice: Can we go in now?
Lucia: 应该可以了吧
Lucia: We should be able to.
Lucia: 他应该扫完了
Lucia: He should be done scanning.
Katrina:  发短信
Katrina: Send a text.
Katrina:  他考本校吧
Katrina: Is he applying to our school?
Katrina:  他本来是同济大学啊
Katrina: He was originally at Tongji University.
Katrina:  还有就是
Katrina: And also...
Katrina:  我觉得我跟他未来规划完全不一样
Katrina: I feel like our future plans are completely different.
Katrina:  因为他当时他考研择校比我早嘛
Katrina: Because he chose his grad school earlier than I did.
Katrina:  就是关于就是我们俩这个分支问题
Katrina: It's about our branching paths.
Katrina:  我们本来还是想大家往一个地方跑
Katrina: We originally wanted to head to the same place.
Katrina:  就一个地域吧
Katrina: Just to the same region.
Katrina:  中部东部什么的
Katrina: Somewhere in the central or eastern areas.
Shure:  那你们是考虑的很很远一些是吗
Shure: So you guys were thinking far ahead, huh?
Katrina:  我已经就是
Katrina: I've already...
Katrina:  我觉得当时觉得没什么
Katrina: At that time, I didn't think much of it.
Katrina:  我谈恋爱就是没什么问题就能相处啊
Katrina: I thought dating was no big deal, we could just get along.
Katrina:  就能继续下去啊
Katrina: And just continue.
Katrina:  然后他
Katrina: But he...
Katrina:  他就没什么规划的包括他考研的
Katrina: He didn't have much of a plan, even for his grad school.
Katrina:  包括他考研择校还还是我问他
Katrina: When it came to choosing his grad school, it was me who asked him.
Katrina:  我说你打算考哪个
Katrina: I asked which one he was planning to go to.
Katrina:  就说我们俩尽量往一个地方就
Katrina: So we could try to be in the same place.
Katrina:  我可能更希望男生会有担当一点
Katrina: I hoped he'd be more responsible.
Katrina:  就去计划一些这些事
Katrina: And plan these things out.
Katrina:  可能他是p人吧
Katrina: Maybe he's a P-type person.
Katrina:  我当时没有研究MBTI啊这种东西
Katrina: I didn't know about MBTI at the time.
Katrina:  你知道吧
Katrina: You know?
Katrina:  然后我就希望
Katrina: So I just hoped...
Katrina:  我们俩就是有一个明确的规划
Katrina: We could have a clear plan.
Katrina:  要不然就异地遥遥无期啊
Katrina: Otherwise, long-distance would be endless.
Katrina:  看研究生跟我就越隔越远
Katrina: The gap between us would just grow wider.
Katrina:  武汉到重庆变成南京到重庆
Katrina: From Wuhan to Chongqing, then Nanjing to Chongqing.
Katrina:  然后他可能要他
Katrina: And then he might...
Katrina:  他学材料
Katrina: He's studying materials science.
Katrina:  材料在中部的国企比较多
Katrina: There are more state-owned enterprises in the central region.
Katrina:  他要留那我留我可能去杭州那边
Katrina: If he stays there, I might go to Hangzhou.
Katrina:  然后那就就就遥遥无期你知道吧
Katrina: And then it would just be endless, you know?
Katrina:  而且他也没有给我一个那种比较
Katrina: Plus, he didn't give me a solid plan.
Katrina:  像样子的规划
Katrina: A plan that looked promising.
Alice:啊，多着呢，充着呢
Lucia: 加一嗯
Lucia: Me too, yeah.
Shure:  废话
Shure: Nonsense
Katrina:  超爽
Katrina: Super cool
Katrina:  早分早分
Katrina: Early separation, early relief
Katrina:  哈哈当时也有人问我要微信啊
Katrina: Haha, someone even asked for my WeChat back then
Shure:  当时有人跟我要微信啊
Shure: Someone asked for my WeChat back then
Nicous:  有有对象的时候也可以加微信
Nicous: You can add WeChat even if you're in a relationship
Shure:  咦谢冰竹你干什么
Shure: Hey Xie Bingzhu, what are you doing?
Katrina:  大一的时候因为我自己也跟男生
Katrina: In my freshman year, because I also hung out with guys
Katrina:  就是我性格比较像男生
Katrina: I mean, my personality is more like a guy
Katrina:  我就高中也跟男生玩的比较多嘛
Katrina: I also hung out with guys a lot in high school
Katrina:  所以我不管他异性朋友
Katrina: So I don't mind his female friends
Katrina:  然后我就比较相信他那种
Katrina: And I trusted him a lot
Katrina:  然后大一的时候
Katrina: Then in my freshman year
Katrina:  那女生就是他所谓的女闺蜜
Katrina: That girl, who he called his best female friend
Katrina:  就在他女在东华大学
Katrina: She was at Donghua University
Katrina:  然后就社团喝醉酒了
Katrina: And got drunk at a club event
Katrina:  就给他半夜打电话
Katrina: Then called him in the middle of the night
Katrina:  然后他早上还问人家
Katrina: And he asked her in the morning
Katrina:  有没有安全到学校
Katrina: If she got back to school safely
Lucia: 你的灯灭了哈哈哈
Lucia: Your light went out, hahaha
Jake:嗯是我也没电了
Jake: Yeah, I ran out of battery too
Shure:  半夜打电话
Shure: Calling in the middle of the night
Nicous:  三个人相处很好
Nicous: The three of them get along well
Shure:  只是半夜打电话而已
Shure: Just a call in the middle of the night
Shure:  没有半夜半夜半夜睡
Shure: Midnight, midnight, midnight sleeping
Shure:  睡到一起已经不错了你知道吧
Shure: Sleeping together is already quite something, you know
Katrina:  然后然后
Katrina: And then, and then
Alice: 今天结束了吗
Alice: Are we done for today?
Jake: 没有对着每个房间讲
Jake: No, let's go room to room
Jake: 吹吹牛逼就结束了
Jake: Just chat and we'll be done
Alice: 什么时候开始
Alice: When do we start?
Jake:现在吧
Jake: Now, I guess
Alice:好
Alice: Okay
Lucia: 啊他要冲到10%以上才能开机
Lucia: Ah, it needs to charge over 10% to turn on
Lucia: 就是我们现在要打一下草稿是吗
Lucia: So we need to draft something now, right?
Lucia: 吹牛皮也要打一下草稿
Lucia: Even for chatting, we need a draft
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Lucia: 没什么草稿
Lucia: No need for a draft
Lucia: 我可以申请拥有一只章鱼吗
Lucia: Can I apply to have an octopus?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake: 申请什么有什么章鱼
Jake: What are you applying for with an octopus?
Lucia: 把它当成一个装饰
Lucia: Just treat it as a decoration.
Alice: 这快递地址能发在群里吗
Alice: Can you post the delivery address in the group?
Lucia: 不是活的
Lucia: It's not alive.
Lucia: 是那个毛绒玩具了
Lucia: It's that plush toy.
Katrina:  然后那次那那次就分手
Katrina: Then we broke up that time.
Katrina:  然后不知道自己哄回来了
Katrina: And I somehow managed to get him back.
Katrina:  哄回来给我买两支香奈儿口红
Katrina: He bought me two Chanel lipsticks to make up.
Lucia: 我还在想我需要什么其他的蓝色装饰
Lucia: I'm still thinking about what other blue decorations I need.
Lucia: 让他看起来更
Lucia: To make it look more...
Alice:欧根纱
Alice: Organza.
Lucia: 蓝色欧根纱
Lucia: Blue organza.
Alice: 嗯一种很梦幻的材料
Alice: Yeah, it's a dreamy material.
Lucia: 我大概知道它什么样
Lucia: I kind of know what it looks like.
Lucia: 有裙子用那个材料做的
Lucia: Some dresses are made of that material.
Alice: 流光溢彩
Alice: Shimmery and colorful.
Katrina:  我靠我从来没骂过人
Katrina: Oh my, I've never cursed at anyone.
Katrina:  因为我当时是这样想的
Katrina: Because I was thinking...
Katrina:  人家给你拍照也有苦
Katrina: The person taking photos for you has their struggles too.
Nicous:  就是没有功劳也有苦
Nicous: Even if they haven't done much, they still tried.
Katrina:  嗯嗯就是
Katrina: Yeah, exactly.
Katrina:  我不会去骂人家对不对
Katrina: I wouldn't curse at them, right?
Katrina:  哎我觉得可p可p
Katrina: I think it's okay to edit the photos...
Katrina:  或者就是哎
Katrina: Or just...
Katrina:  没事大不了就不发这朋友圈啊
Katrina: It's fine, just don't post them on social media.
Katrina:  太懂事了
Katrina: So considerate.
Katrina:  谁他妈跟我谈
Katrina: Whoever dates me...
Katrina:  真是有福了
Katrina: Is really lucky.
Katrina:  从来没把骂过他
Katrina: I've never cursed at him.
Katrina:  然后包括我分手以后
Katrina: Even after we broke up.
Katrina:  我看我室友他们谈恋爱
Katrina: I see my roommates in their relationships.
Katrina:  他们是直接就可能说话就比较直
Katrina: They speak quite bluntly.
Katrina:  他们说哎你这样太邋遢太丑了
Katrina: They would say things like, "You're too sloppy and ugly."
Katrina:  我靠从来没有说过带脏字的哎
Katrina: Oh my, I've never said anything with swear words.
Lucia: 让我看看
Lucia: Let me see.
Alice: 你竟然有网
Alice: You actually have internet?
Lucia: 嗯有网
Lucia: Yeah, I have internet.
Alice:我去
Alice: Wow.
Lucia: 咱们这是张家湾吗
Lucia: Are we in Zhangjiawan?
Lucia: 这什么地方
Lucia: Where is this place?
Lucia: 他怎么给我自动定位到
Lucia: How did it automatically locate me
Lucia: 张
Lucia: Zhang
Lucia: 家湾
Lucia: Jiawan
Lucia: 啊还真在这附近啊let me check
Lucia: Ah, it's really nearby. Let me check.
Lucia: 照片墙照片打印机
Lucia: Photo wall, photo printer
Lucia: 这个也很有用
Lucia: This is also very useful
Alice: 困了困了
Alice: I'm so sleepy
Lucia: 加一
Lucia: Same here
Alice: 现在能先卸妆吗
Alice: Can I remove my makeup now?
Lucia: 可能应该也可以吧
Lucia: Maybe you can
Alice:哎，那不得把眼镜去了
Alice:哎
Lucia: 啊小心等一次这个还连着呢
Lucia: Ah, be careful, this is still connected
Alice:啊对
Alice: Oh, right
Lucia: 嗯咱俩要不要换一下充电宝
Lucia: Hmm, should we swap power banks?
Alice:累了
Lucia: 你需要充手机吗
Lucia: Do you need to charge your phone?
Alice: 嗯不需要
Alice: Hmm, no
Lucia: 那可以换一下吗
Lucia: Can we swap then?
Alice: 没事我先站一会吧
Alice: It's okay, I'll just stand for a bit
Alice: 嗯好困
Alice: I'm so sleepy
Lucia: 觉得这个派他应该还好着吧
Lucia: I think this pie should still be good
Lucia: 我有点想把它吃了
Lucia: I'm kind of tempted to eat it
Alice: 你打一下
Alice: Go for it
Lucia: 其实我也不饿
Lucia: Actually, I'm not hungry
Lucia: 但我就是有点想吃
Lucia: But I just want to eat
Alice: 你用微波炉热它一下吧
Alice: Warm it up in the microwave
Lucia: 呃对
Lucia: Uh, yeah
Lucia: 我用微波炉热一下
Lucia: I'll microwave it
Lucia: 看一眼它没坏吧
Lucia: Check if it's still good
Lucia: 这么短时间应该不会长毛
Lucia: It shouldn't go bad so quickly
Alice: 没它是有盐有糖的
Alice: No, it's got salt and sugar
Lucia: 嗯那我就热一下
Lucia: Alright, I'll warm it up
Lucia: 上面这微波炉
Lucia: The microwave's on top
Lucia: 底下是烤箱
Lucia: Oven's below
Lucia: 只能直接放
Lucia: Just put it in directly
Lucia: 算了我那个啥吧
Lucia: Nevermind, I'll use a plate
Lucia: 我决定给他找个盘子
Lucia: I've decided to find a plate for it
Lucia: 诶我们的纸
Lucia: Hey, where's our paper
Jake: 来吧
Jake: Come on
Jake:来吧
Jake: 好开吹吧
Jake: Alright, let's start
Alice: 就我们仨
Alice: Just the three of us.
Jake: 都来了
Jake: Everyone's here.
Jake: 别门得关了
Jake: Close the door.
Jake: 哈哈哈多少有点离谱
Jake: Haha, this is kinda ridiculous.
Jake: 进来吧进来吧
Jake: Come on in, come on in.
Jake: 哎开开了
Jake: Oh, it's open now.
Choiszt:  今天晚上GoPro还导吗
Choiszt: Are we transferring the GoPro footage tonight?
Jake: 导
Jake: Yes.
Choiszt:  这次应该快
Choiszt: It should be quick this time.
Jake:OK了
Jake: OK.
Jake: 希望如此吧
Jake: Let's hope so.
Jake: 这不要立flag
Jake: Let's not jinx it.
Jake: 真的
Jake: Seriously.
Jake: 我靠行行
Jake: Oh man, alright, alright.
Jake: 我靠这真的真的
Jake: Oh man, this is really something.
Jake: 做梦时候就在想这个
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Jake: 主要是插电不方便
Jake: The main issue is it's not convenient to plug in.
Lucia: 啊我突然有点想把那个Pad吃了哦
Lucia: Ah, I suddenly feel like eating that Pad.
Lucia: 决定来点夜宵
Lucia: Decided to have a midnight snack.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 不是你那拍照不给我录啥意思
Jake: Why didn't you let me record when you took the picture?
Jake: 对就聊聊就吹吹牛就拉倒
Jake: Yeah, just chatting and bragging, that's it.
Jake: 啊不交换礼物
Jake: Oh, no gift exchange.
Jake: 明早交换礼物
Jake: We'll exchange gifts tomorrow morning.
Jake: 什么派
Jake: What pie?
Lucia: 我还没吃
Lucia: I haven't eaten it yet.
Lucia: 我尝一口告诉你哦
Lucia: Let me take a bite and I'll tell you.
Jake: 你还不知道什么派
Jake: You don't know what pie it is?
Lucia: 嗯薛定鄂的派
Lucia: Hmm, Schrödinger's pie.
Katrina:  显示电量太低
Katrina: The battery is too low.
Jake: 哦OK
Jake: Oh, OK.
Jake: 你给他充一会
Jake: Charge it for a while.
Jake: 你也没电了
Jake: You're out of battery too.
Jake: 你没电了呀
Jake: You're out of battery.
Jake: 你没电了
Jake: 你连不上看不了
Jake: You can't connect, you can't watch.
Lucia: no that's mine
Lucia: No, that's mine.
Lucia: 哈哈当然你可以用
Lucia: Haha, of course you can use it.
Katrina:  这个味道变了吗
Katrina: Has the taste changed?
Lucia: 没有昨天的吧这是
Lucia: This isn't from yesterday, right?
Lucia: 这么甜应该不容易坏
Lucia: It's so sweet, it shouldn't go bad easily.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Katrina:  西柚就是比橙汁兑着好
Katrina: Grapefruit is better mixed with orange juice.
Lucia: 橙汁适合加入那个龙舌兰
Lucia: Orange juice goes well with tequila.
Lucia: 好这个薛定谔的派是红豆味的
Lucia: Okay, this Schrödinger's pie is red bean flavored.
Jake: 红豆味哈哈红豆
Jake: Red bean flavor, haha, red bean.
Jake: 他得冲到5%左右吧
Jake: It should reach around 5%, right?
Jake: 10% 嗯
Jake: 10%, hmm.
Jake: 对就是
Jake: Yes, exactly.
Jake: 其实是一伙人进去围观
Jake: Actually, it's a group of people coming in to watch.
Lucia: 啊我眼镜开着呢
Lucia: Ah, my glasses are on.
Jake: 哈哈哈执法执法记录仪执法记录仪
Jake: Hahaha, law enforcement recorder, law enforcement recorder.
Lucia: 我眼镜开着呢
Lucia: My glasses are on.
Lucia: 谨言慎行啊哈哈
Lucia: Be cautious, haha.
Shure:  好有经验好有经验什么鬼
Shure: So experienced, so experienced, what the heck.
Katrina:  这到底是什么呀
Katrina: What is this exactly?
Nicous:  按的按
Nicous: Press it, press it.
Nicous:  就是是一和7
Nicous: It's one and seven.
Jake: 这是什么呃
Jake: What is this, uh?
Nicous:  这是什么
Nicous: What is this?
Nicous:  那这个一和7的
Nicous: This one and seven thing.
Nicous:  嗯这就是一个
Nicous: Hmm, this is just a...
Lucia: 嗯这是地球吗
Lucia: Hmm, is this Earth?
Lucia: 有点像是吧
Lucia: It kind of looks like it, right?
Jake: 这是什么方向呢
Jake: What direction is this?
Jake: 澳大利亚
Jake: Australia.
Jake: 南极
Jake: Antarctica.
Lucia: 这可以是新西兰
Lucia: This could be New Zealand.
Lucia: 虽然比例有点不对
Lucia: Although the scale is a bit off.
Lucia: 但他可以
Lucia: But it works.
Nicous:  卧槽
Nicous: Whoa.
Nicous: 我这不明天就肺癌
Nicous: I'll get lung cancer by tomorrow.
Nicous:  你是人吗
Nicous: Are you even human?
Jake: 你直接吃了吧
Jake: Just eat it directly.
Nicous: 我靠我他妈吃了都比抽健康
Nicous: Damn, eating it is healthier than smoking.
Nicous:  就是减少
Nicous: Just reduce it.
Nicous:  我说你这也太抽象了拍我
Nicous: I'm telling you, this is too abstract, film me.
Choiszt:  我以为是因为我看那个什么电视
Choiszt: I thought it was because I was watching that TV show.
Katrina:  对方很能很容易看到我的情绪波动
Katrina: The other side can easily see my mood swings.
Katrina: 但是呢我只要那只要那发一条
Katrina: But I just need to, just need to send one message.
Jake: 你在这秀
Jake: You're showing off.
Jake: 哈哈不给看
Jake: Haha, not letting you see.
Shure:  哎呀啊啊
Shure: Oh noooo.
Katrina:  好恶心啊
Katrina: That's so gross.
Nicous: 给你带来了快乐你开着呢
Nicous: It brought you joy, didn't it?
Nicous:  你觉得我们俩口音像吗
Nicous: Do you think our accents sound alike?
Jake: 不像
Jake: Not at all.
Nicous: 但是但是我我那些同学听到我
Nicous: But, but my classmates all say...
:Jake:我知道我知道哈哈
Jake: I know, I know, haha.
Katrina: 但是我觉得你口音特别像安徽人
Katrina: But I think your accent sounds just like someone from Anhui.
Nicous: 我就是安徽的
Nicous: I am from Anhui.
Nicous: 我马鞍山马鞍山的
Nicous: I'm from Ma'anshan.
Jake: 哎你也没电了
Jake: Oh, your battery's dead too.
Tasha: 我刚充上电了已经
Tasha: I just charged it.
Jake: 好吧我们走吧
Jake: Okay, let's go.
Jake: 我感觉凑不了凑不到人
Jake: I feel like we can't gather enough people.
Jake: 喝多了
Jake: Drank too much.
Jake: 意思一下
Jake: Just a little bit.
Katrina:  OK
Katrina: OK.
Katrina:  哎这现在还不能拔是吧
Katrina: Hey, I still can't unplug this, right?
Shure: what
Shure: What?
Lucia: 那根线上还写着我名字呢
Lucia: My name is written on that cable.
Lucia: 好吧原来您也看过魔剑
Lucia: Alright, so you've seen Magic Sword too.
Lucia: 我还害怕
Lucia: I was scared.
Lucia: 我今天讲那个关于咕噜的冷笑话
Lucia: I told a joke about Gollum today.
Lucia: 没人听懂来着
Lucia: No one got it.
Katrina:  来吧来吧
Katrina: Come on, come on.
Jake:来吧
Jake: Come on.
Shure:  先先先介绍什么
Shure: What should we introduce first?
Jake: 你开了吗你
Jake: Did you start it?
Katrina:  没开
Katrina: Not yet.
Shure: 好没开
Shure: Okay, not yet.
Jake: 先先聊到克星啊
Jake: Let's first talk about the nemesis.
Alice: 都要进来吗
Alice: Is everyone coming in?
Jake: 对毕竟你收拾过了吧
Jake: Yes, since you cleaned up, right?
Alice: 啊我的想法就是
Alice: Uh, my idea is...
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice: 因为这个房间比较小
Alice: Because this room is quite small.
Alice: 然后这个白色占的面积特别大
Alice: And the white area takes up a lot of space.
Alice: 我就打算买一个床单
Alice: I'm planning to buy a bedsheet.
Alice: 对
Alice: Yeah.
Alice: 然后就整体上就看起来被改造过了
Alice: Then the whole thing will look like it’s been transformed.
Alice: 然后搞一个桌布
Alice: And then I'll get a tablecloth.
Alice: 然后这个上面放一个微型的小的
Alice: I'll place a miniature landscape on it.
Alice: 小的景观
Alice: A small one.
Alice: 微型景观
Alice: A miniature landscape.
Alice: 然后有海藻球
Alice: And it’ll have some marimo balls.
Alice: 然后买一个杯垫
Alice: Then I'll buy a coaster.
Alice: 然后上面放一个桂花味的香薰
Alice: And place an osmanthus-scented candle on it.
Alice: 整体就是一个跟这个米黄色搭相近的
Alice: The whole setup will match this beige color.
Alice: 一个奶绿色吧左右的
Alice: With a kind of milky green tone, I guess.
Alice: 大概就是这样
Alice: That’s about it.
Jake: 这叫啥主题呢
Jake: What theme is this?
Jake: 没关系
Jake: Never mind.
Alice: 初春主题
Alice: Early spring theme.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Yep.
Jake: make sense
Jake: Makes sense.
Jake: 好make sense
Jake: Okay, makes sense.
Alice: OK了啊就这样
Alice: Alright, that's it then.
Jake: 来看你怎么吹牛逼
Jake: Let’s see how you boast.
Jake: 还不能吹你的是吧那我
Jake: You can’t boast about yours, right? So I...
Jake: 好那我们先上楼吧
Jake: Alright, let’s head upstairs first.
Jake: 来
Jake: Come on.
Jake: 就赛博主题
Jake: It’s a cyber theme.
Lucia: 哈哈哈已经装修好了
Lucia: Haha, it's already decorated.
Jake: 完工完工状态
Jake: Finished, in a completed state.
Jake:怎么样
Jake: So, what do you think?
Lucia: 进度100%
Lucia: Progress is 100%.
Jake: 还是蓝色
Jake: Still blue.
Jake: 地球地球赛博
Jake: Earth, earth cyber theme.
Lucia: 对对
Lucia: Right, right.
Lucia: 蓝白相间
Lucia: Blue and white.
Jake: 对停电一小时电脑都开着
Jake: Yeah, even with a power outage, the computers are still running.
Lucia: 哦对这是科幻主题吧
Lucia: Oh right, it’s a sci-fi theme, right?
Jake: 叫什么动物派对
Jake: What's this animal party thing called?
Katrina: 动物派对
Katrina: Animal Party.
Jake: 动物派对动物partyOK
Jake: Animal Party, animal party, okay.
Katrina:  这边全都是那种画就是那种偏春天
Katrina: Over here, we have all these paintings, leaning towards spring.
Katrina:  然后动物的
Katrina: And animals.
Katrina:  然后这边也搞一个那个画
Katrina: And then put a picture here too.
Katrina:  就是买那个美纹纸贴一个大的那个
Katrina: Like, buy some masking tape and put up a big one.
Katrina:  呃海报一样的
Katrina: Uh, like a big poster.
Katrina:  然后这边挂一个那个壁画
Katrina: And then hang a mural over here.
Katrina:  然后这边摆几个小娃娃
Katrina: Then put some small dolls here.
Katrina:  就是全部是动物的那种
Katrina: Like, all of them should be animals.
Katrina:  然后地上搞一个那个地毯
Katrina: And then put a carpet on the floor.
Katrina:  就是那种苔藓的那种形状的
Katrina: Like, the kind that looks like moss.
Katrina:  然后那那那边还有一部分的区域
Katrina: And then, there's another part of the area.
Katrina:  打算就放我的那个花
Katrina: I plan to put my flowers.
Katrina:  然后还有一个那个香薰小夜灯
Katrina: And also an aroma diffuser night light.
Katrina:  就是那香薰既能香
Katrina: That way, it both smells nice.
Katrina:  又有那个夜灯的功能
Katrina: And functions as a night light.
Katrina:  然后床上放一个松
Katrina: Then put a pine... uh, what do you call it, a pine tree?
Katrina:  嗯那个松树的叫什么松树
Katrina: Haha, a pine tree stuffed toy.
Katrina:  哈哈松树的那个玩偶
Katrina: A pillow, and also a little fox stuffed toy.
Katrina:  抱枕然后再放一只小狐狸的那个玩偶
Katrina: And that's about it.
Katrina:  然后差不多就是这样
Katrina: Yeah, everything will have animal elements.
Katrina:  对就是全部都是动物的元素
Katrina: And the overall theme will be green.
Katrina:  然后就是整体是绿色的基调
Katrina: And everything is bought.
Katrina:  然后都买好了
Katrina: All ready to go.
Jake: 哦挺好嗯差不多5,000块钱
Jake: Oh nice, about 5,000 yuan.
Jake: 好挺好哈哈哈没有没有没有
Jake: Good, very good, hahaha, no, no, no.
Katrina:  因为反正我要换到我新家去
Katrina: Because I'm moving to my new place.
Jake: 哦OK
Jake: Oh, okay.
Jake: 我我我我也很喜欢这个房间
Jake: I, I, I really like this room too.
Jake: 因为这是我房间原来的样子
Jake: Because it was my room originally.
Katrina:  嗯对
Katrina: Yeah.
Jake: 现在变成了那个样子
Jake: Now it looks like this.
Tasha: 房间我想要做成一个色彩
Tasha: I want to make the room colorful.
Tasha: 多巴胺的那种
Tasha: Like, dopamine colors.
Tasha: 嗯然后我决定再多用一些蓝色
Tasha: Hmm, then I'll decide to use more blue.
Jake: 你还在充电是吧
Jake: Are you still charging?
Tasha: 蓝色和粉色的元素
Tasha: Blue and pink elements.
Tasha: 嗯嗯弄个地毯
Tasha: Hmm, and get a carpet.
Tasha: 换个床单
Tasha: Change the bedsheet.
Tasha: 再搞一点装饰画
Tasha: Add some decorative paintings.
Tasha: 然后那个窗户
Tasha: And for the window.
Tasha: 我想把它那个贴那种
Tasha: I want to put up those...
Tasha: 就
Tasha: Just...
Tasha: 相当于是打开窗户的一个景色的那种
Tasha: It's like the view you get when you open a window.
Tasha: 窗布嗯嗯
Tasha: Window curtains, yeah.
Lucia: 这样子他就会有那种夏天的感觉
Lucia: This way, it gives off that summer vibe.
Jake: 叫什么来着
Jake: What was it called again?
Katrina:  你的主题
Katrina: Your theme.
Tasha: 多巴胺多巴胺
Tasha: Dopamine, dopamine.
Jake:多巴胺
Jake: Dopamine.
Lucia: 是这个主题吗
Lucia: Is that the theme?
Lucia: 我记得对吧
Lucia: I remember, right?
Jake: 到路亚了
Jake: It's up to you now.
Lucia: 哎呀我这个牛的草稿还没有打好
Lucia: Oh no, I haven't even finished my draft.
Lucia: 大家就凑合着听一听
Lucia: Everyone, just bear with me.
Lucia: 就是我这个房间
Lucia: So, this room of mine...
Lucia: 他很不巧就没有挂钩
Lucia: It just happens to not have a hook.
Lucia: 然后这个桌子
Lucia: And then this table...
Jake:你后面其实有个挂钩
Jake: Actually, there's a hook behind you.
Jake: 但是啥也不是
Jake: But it's useless.
Lucia: 哦那个后面啊
Lucia: Oh, the one behind?
Lucia: 其实大家也看不到了
Lucia: Actually, no one can see it.
Lucia: 就是姑且认为是他没有吧
Lucia: So let's just assume it's not there.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 所以我的想法是
Lucia: So my idea is...
Lucia: 我可能把这个搬出去
Lucia: I might move this out.
Lucia: 然后在这里放一个小桌子
Lucia: And put a small table here.
Lucia: 然后可以给上面盖一个桌布
Lucia: And then put a tablecloth on it.
Lucia: 然后我现在想的大概是蓝白这种主题
Lucia: And right now I'm thinking of a blue and white theme.
Lucia: 色调就是搞一个偏地中海这种风格
Lucia: The color scheme would be Mediterranean style.
Lucia: 或者说面朝大海
Lucia: Or like facing the sea.
Lucia: 春暖花开这样
Lucia: Spring flowers blooming.
Lucia: 对然后这边的话
Lucia: Yes, and over here...
Lucia: 到时候可能还要
Lucia: Maybe later...
Lucia: 我明天还要再看一下格局
Lucia: I'll need to look at the layout again tomorrow.
Lucia: 如果合适可能想放一个照片墙
Lucia: If it fits, I might put a photo wall here.
Lucia: 然后给上面挂一些渔网啊
Lucia: And hang some fishing nets or...
Lucia: 或者贝壳这样的东西
Lucia: Or some shells on it.
Lucia: 然后也可以装饰一些照片
Lucia: And also decorate it with some photos.
Lucia: 或者小的那种照贴画
Lucia: Or small picture stickers.
Lucia: 明信片
Lucia: Postcards.
Lucia: 嗯然后床单的话
Lucia: And for the bed sheets...
Lucia: 就是因为这个床
Lucia: Because this bed...
Lucia: 他占的面积实在是很大
Lucia: It takes up a lot of space.
Lucia: 所以呃
Lucia: So, um...
Lucia: 我还在想是买一个就是蓝色的
Lucia: I'm still thinking whether to buy a blue one.
Lucia: 就是他的色调和明度
Lucia: Like its tone and brightness.
Lucia: 这些都跟房间还比较符合的床单呢
Lucia: These would match the room quite well, you know, the bed sheets.
Lucia: 还是买两个就是小抱枕
Lucia: Or should I get two small pillows instead?
Alice: 有尺子吗卷尺
Alice: Do we have a ruler or a tape measure?
Nicous:  有
Nicous: Yeah.
Alice: 哦谢谢
Alice: Oh, thanks.
Katrina:  好可怕这个人
Katrina: This person is so scary.
Jake: 这个这个得团队讨论一下
Jake: This, this needs a team discussion.
Jake: 要不要毙掉
Jake: Should we get rid of it?
Jake: 哈哈哈好
Jake: Hahaha, okay.
Jake: 给我们增加了一些工作量挺好
Jake: It added some work for us, which is good.
Jake: 好那我们今天就这样明早见
Jake: Alright, that's it for today. See you tomorrow morning.
Katrina: 下班
Katrina: End of the day.
Jake: 下班下班下班
Jake: End of the day, end of the day.
Shure:  下班拜拜
Shure: End of the day, bye.
Jake: 拜拜放这吧
Jake: Bye, just leave it here.
Katrina:  再见了赛博人生
Katrina: Goodbye, cyber life.